se classer parmi les premiers c'est
aussi difficile dans le domaine de la
mode que dans celui du sport on
n'imagine pas la somme de volonté qu'il
faut un petit et jeune couturier pour
devenir grand il lui faut trouver sa
griffe
son style se faire connaître et faire
reconnaître par les siens c'est le cas
de celui que nous vous présentons ce
soir pour terminer ce journal valérie
forgues romantiques ses robes d'herbes à
danser à aimer pour cv des drapés ou
foncée elles ont un éclatant mélange du
précieux et du frivole
jaloux
la femme fait j'adore le fameux
féminines élégant ou the romantics les
femmes femmes sur est d abord d ailleurs
vous verrez non plus jamais le manteau
nu très petit tailleur chez moi mais
beaucoup de la fébrilité tout le temps
frivole non sérieux sa spécialité les
robes de mariée
behiels aujourd'hui un jeune créateur un
nouveau style
chacun pense